jean-jacques algérie lewiston
[Applaudissements]
car
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors que lewis bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue cole harbour gagnant win in
the mind of which has et votre
interprète
oui d'accord jerry lewis acteurs
réalisateurs inventeur du téléthon merci
d'avoir choisi tout le monde en parle
est-ce que je suis content d'être à
paris à la bimbo un frêne drôme la
canadienne maison d'un deuxième foyer
alors vous dirais les wings ont reçu aux
usa et que je commente à qatar b la
seule chose qui me remonte le moral
c2 prend un avion et d'aller à paris ou
à nice comme down
quand je deviens un as yet de jerez et
que je suis dépressif iron air france
air from two paris et bien paré merci
hein
et oui c'est génial on sent une beauté
lisse et respect ce n'est pas retenu ses
yeux c'est l'expert à noeux-les-mines
folie pas fautif à la 45 guy labrie
horrible à roland garros alors jerry
lewis en france vous êtes une star
depuis les années 60 que vous étiez
encensé par la critique la critique
intellos des cahiers du cinéma et de la
revue positif
c'est pareil en europe c'est pareil au
japon c'est pareil en australie
comment expliquez vous vous soyez moins
aimé aux usa que dans le reste du monde
nick watney atzmon y en a qui ne sont
pas intelligents
alors qu'eric vous aimait beaucoup la
france la france vous aime beaucoup mais
que pensez vous de la position française
sur la guerre en irak à itunes à get
into pratique il ne parle jamais de
politique
victor fries ou chrome lui aurait dit et
fait jaser déjà de la comédie c'est pas
la peine d'en faire plus docteur faye
could be as poney as bouche du doigt les
petits drôles quelle chance vous alors
vous avez donné beaucoup de plaisir au
cinéma d'hier il est oui et en ce qui me
concerne avec docteur jerry et mister
love il ya ce extraordinaire quand il
est transformé et qui sort et que on le
voit pas nous on voit les gens qui le
regarde et on sait pas quelle tête il a
c'est la première fois que moi j'ai pris
conscience de ce qui était la
réalisation au cinéma dit noni place was
my libre enveloppe
oui c'était sa façon de montrer l'amour
qu'il avait un nid d'amour to machine
tout est de damas ci dessous du héros
faire tout en vous devez donner
également beaucoup de plaisir dans le
film avec robert de niro le film de
martin scorsese ce qui s'appelle la
valse des pantins qui nous permet d'y
kings of comedy bien sûr mais ce qu'on
savait pas c'est que vous souffriez le
martyre ya ce pendant 37 ans tous les
jours vous avez souffert pendant 37 ans
aung san sui doute rise up stoupy faut
ni poésie musicale non un acte décolleté
ni tram down to men ar créac'h nitoo
ouais to my way hosting rome voilà qui
dit c'est que quand il était sur scène
pendant deux heures ils avaient
l'adrénaline qui lui donnait de
l'énergie
mais dès que le rideau tombe et il avait
besoin de deux personnes pour le ramener
dans sa loge
oui oui alors c'est dû au fait que vous
faisiez vos cascades vous même mois oui
mais voila voila et est la spécialité de
jerry lewis était de tomber de sa
hauteur en piano du piano et toujours
sur sa colonne vertébrale
voilà qui est oui c'est beaucoup tomber
nouvelle klaus
jusqu'au jour où le 20 mars 1965
jerry lewis explose deux vertèbres dans
le bas de la colonne vertébrale en
intéressant sur un câble métallique et à
deux millimètres près votre colonne
vertébrale était foutue soir il a été
paralysé pendant 27 heures un gay
narbonne pendant 37 ans pour sortir du
lit ça vous montrer when do
à
pauli qui a baigné à l'effort on fait
des piqûres on vous donne des pilules et
vous devenez accro aux antidouleurs et
au perco dans à cette époque là vous
devenez un toxicomane mais oui il y en
avoir initié vous ne travaillez pas vous
êtes assis sans bouger et à l'époque
vous avez des ulcères à l'estomac à
cause de l'abus de médicaments des
onglons et là vous envisagé le suicide
comme une délivrance
yes un jour il avait un revolver il
russe flinguer ayasse n'diaye bah enoc
il entend 10 à 6 0 6 7 des 10 voire you
doing ce que je dis papa qu'est ce que
tu fais tiger woods à houston usa today
show il avait un pistolet dans son show
et il a dit à sa fille qu'il est en
train de répéter
en fait il voulait vraiment se suicider
et là effectivement vous avez trouvé un
système qui s'appelle la neuro
simulation alors si ces deux électrodes
qu'on met sur la colonne vertébrale
1 et puis à l'intérieur de l'abdomen
vous avez un petit pays mais coeur 1
dans le ventre et vous avez une
télécommande
alors c'est extraordinaire c'est qu'avec
sa télécommande quand il a mal il règle
son fils né coeur qui envoie des ondes
sur les deux électrodes qui sont sur la
colonne vertébrale il a uni la russie la
douleur et la une et dwan saône et loire
la direction voit bien là vous attendre
un de stimuler le pêcheur que vous avez
dans le ventre
oui elle na no pain no paix interne au
bâti tout âge et payne idaho
voilà donc il était obligé de temps en
temps comme ça de redémarrer son
pacemaker qui travaille sur les
électrodes qui sont sur la colonne
vertébrale
y'en a combien de temps que vous avez
s'arsouiller deux ans et prom queen teen
wolf eyes and to win the exact mais le
21 avril cela fera deux ans exactement
oui il utilise ça et pourquoi vous
n'avez pas utilisé avant aydin normal
ils savaient pas que ça existait un
manipule nano aux baleines disease
il dit que la douleur chronique est une
maladie silencieuse
oui un petit peu un sixième de la
population française princecraft à dému
une douleur chronique seventeen made in
france pipe en amérique au beau fixe et
pas seulement en irak mais c'est de
l'espoir
oui oui oui nous on appâte en france oui
de rieter alors je n'ai pas dis et je le
docteur climatologues
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez la jambe aux simulations
north bay je ne connais pas la
neurostimulation pour une raison d'abord
c'est que voilà le la la prise en compte
de la douleur c'est quand même assez
récent ça date d'à peu près une dizaine
d'années après le combat de deux
médecins et a comme françois bourreau ça
ne s'invente pas qu'ils aient battu
françois moreau qui s'est battu pour
faire reconnaître cette douleur faut
savoir que notamment sur les
prescriptions de morphiniques il a fallu
vraiment le combat de bernard kouchner
d'autres ministres de la santé pour que
ça passe difficile like many d'arc
docteur comme beaucoup de docteurs aux
états unis ne connais pas la
neurostimulation bicross et des hommes
d'antoine qui use autres parce que ça
n'a que 20 ans d'existence inch nails
technology et dans la technologie
d'aujourd'hui
touati you drive by by nuxe 20 ans c'est
comme ça qu'ils ont forgés pour calibrer
secteur là au malawi
picross hybrid reine claude berri match
il a mené avec lui un ami qu'il aime
beaucoup couru soin de beast que milly
une fringue sésame nantes qui est un des
meilleurs comiques français avoir sur ce
see a ghost money and see you yeah
jours
[Musique]
dans les territoires sous marine qui est
un bon ami
voilà vous avez été un des premiers en
france à à célébrer le talent de jerry
lewis
à l'époque effectivement où il a été
découvert par les cahiers du cinéma par
la revue positif il c'est vrai que c'est
la france avec benayoun aussi c'est la
france qui a été le premier pays à
rendre hommage au talent de dire eh oui
il avait dit un jour
l'herbe est plus verte ailleurs ça c'est
vrai j'ai dû dire adieu
non c'est vrai que quand j'ai rencontré
de gérer ça a été un bonheur indicible
c'est à dire qu'au premier jour j'ai
senti quelqu'un avec qui j'étais
complètement en accord
il est venu vers moi il m'a tendu les
bras il était venu à paris pour tourner
boing boing je crois à l'époque et il a
voulu me recevoir parce qu'il avait vu
mon film et il m'a reçu donc dans son
hôtel et m'a tendu les bras et m'a dit
je te connais et c'est vrai qu'à cet
instant j'avais le sentiment que nous
nous connaissions depuis longtemps
beaucoup de gens m'ont dit vous êtes si
différents et moi je pense qu'on est si
proche au contraire parce que les gens
ne voient que les apparences c'est
toujours l'arbre qui cache la forêt
olivier votre fils est là aussi nous
sommes une vidéo non maximum annuel
donné hier à venir
pauli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok oui messieurs merci aurait bien aimé
un très beau très bien alors vous étiez
en 1926 à new york dans le new jersey
votre père s'appelait daniel levy tx10
dany lévis et votre mère ça plairait
rothberg alors vos parents étaient des
comédiens sur scène dans ce qu'on
appelle le bortsch circuit tu sais quoi
le prix c'est quoi le board siècle de 4
km et new york state be used hugo de sa
main c'est les montagnes du 4 et le nord
de new york où les gens allaient passer
l'été au men and ten days to x
voilà et vos parents joués sur scène
dans ces endroits là des chances paris
nice aubry 1
il est des choses s'enfuit par mauvais
temps au coeur des choses cinq jours par
celui de samedi tsonga n
quand vous avez commencé sur scène vous
faisiez brodeur can you spurs d'harry
durimel dare-dare pièce vous souvenez ça
ça y est
mais voilà
[Applaudissements]
ça ne donne à personne kathleen brooks
voilà ce que céline wind chanté à l'âge
de 5 ans sur scène quand ils et elles
étaient dans les quatre avec ses parents
brothers can use père d'anne
c'est-à-dire brodeur est ce que tu peux
me donner un dj sound square oui parce
que là parce que l'airé louer les
chemins de fer était terminée il avait
plus d'argent est ce que tu peux me
donner 10 cents c'est ce que voulait
chanter merci merci beaucoup mieux alors
en 1939 puis nineteen sortie nine à
l'âge de 13 ans il vous avait été exclu
du collège parce que vous avez battu le
directeur du collège qu'elle se bat bien
parce que vous avez quelques remarques
antisémites
oui mais tu es un quad huyghe ans au
windsor mais il est tombé par la semaine
vous avez dit vous allez vite jerry
lewis l'antisémitisme c'est une maladie
comme l'alcoolisme
yes tenait un meeting des mondiaux en
salle au maire why
c'est une maladie comme le racisme à rob
bowman mi saison pleine sous bois mon
père est ouvert à tout le monde
you get what you want one et voudra
verrines et la vidéo à rennais fc vous
traversez la vie d'une façon magnifique
si vous aimez les gens et vous êtes en
enfer si vous ne venez pas
alors que les bruits sont pour lutter
contre l'antisémitisme et perpétuer la
mémoire de la shoah en 1972
vous avez un film qui s'appelle le jour
où le clown pleura oui vous vous êtes à
la fois acteur et réalisateur
si une histoire extraordinaire c'est
l'histoire d'un clown allemand anti nazi
arrêté par la gestapo et emmené dans un
camp de la mort
hélas ce clown est chargé par les nazis
d'emmener les enfants à la chambre à gaz
en les faisant rire pour qu'ils se
rendent pas compte de ce qui leur arrive
il dit qu il la finira un jour oui parce
que ce film n'est jamais sortie n'est
jamais fini non point pour des raisons
sordide de l'agent de droit des raisons
d'argent raison de production des
raisons d'argent comme ça arrive parfois
que le producteur s'en va avec la caisse
mais un n'a pas fini d'espérer de
pouvoir un jour récupérer les pellicules
et les terminaux quand vous avez vu le
film de benigni qui s'appelle la vie est
belle
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils avaient
été au courant de votre projet il était
formidable et très proche de votre idée
quand même il pleure
mieux on va vous faire une interview
check up
[Musique]
quel est l'homme politique qui vous
donne des boutons non pas les nobody
allons bien même des vacances passées
d'importance qu'est ce qui vous fait
vomir dans le cinéma américain
aujourd'hui et snow ball tout ce qui se
montre un les strip-teases car ils
paient pas la comprendre quel est le
comique américain aujourd'hui qui vous
donne de la fièvre de grignoter au sujet
de quelques milk américain voudriez vous
être amnésique nos collègues nous sommes
très heureux la dernière fois que votre
coeur s'est arrêté de battre c'était
pour qui pour sa femme et sa fille
hewson hewson la dernière fois que j'ai
vu des larmes dans les yeux il aurait
payé ce pas trop tôt ça vous fait mal
quand vous voyez des jeunes qui
connaissent pas vos films koska n'ont
pas dit non et quand on vous prend pour
l'animateur du téléthon ça vous fait de
la peine ouais pourquoi tu deit ayad
donne du talent tonnes mais j'ai fait le
téléthon one des lionnes nine hundred
million d'arbres et gégé j'ai ramassé
avignon 900 millions de dollars 8
bon ce n'est qu'une scène un miroir donc
ils peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent moi
j'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire
ça vous fait mal quand vous réalisez que
beaucoup de vos amis sont morts nom de
dragon quest x y ou ok ok a dit non j'ai
besoin de savoir
au stop de chant à apprendre que dans
les journaux on you try to get to be
nice
est-ce que tu essaies de me vendre
mauvais nom john wright b2b à 100 mbits
s était le seul canadien et je peux pas
faire ça chaque soir des bases saines
c'est pour ça que tous mes épaules et
même à y tient j'aime je peux je prends
soin des filles du fbi américain ce mec
droit je ferai tout ce que je peux
prairie aubry goodman le cdeps nomme
très bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]